je plaisante
l'avenir de l'humanité n'est plus entre
ses mains l'avenir de l'humanité n'est
plus entre ses mains mais entre celles
d'intelligence artificielle que nous
avons créées sans nous en rendre compte
des parasites géants mondiaux
ça va ça va vous passer une bonne soirée
je sais que pour un début de dernier tôt
que ça casse un peu l'ambiance 1 à la
fin ça finit bien vous inquiétez pas je
suis jasmin et vous vous pouvez répondre
à cette intox
aitor mike speech oui à votre axe pas du
tout la même chose
déjà qu'on a que 18 minutes pour changer
le monde
ceci dit ça veut dire qu'on est dans le
thème de la soirée un bouger les lignes
18 minutes
on peut bien en perdre une ensemble non
toné puisqu'on va se quitter
disons-nous au revoir 1
allez-y moi je vais montrer l'exemple au
revoir jasmin coach tintin alesi de vous
revoir surtout aux gens que vous avez
qui vous avez dit bonjour tout à l'heure
donc vous c'est pour voir si vous avez
retenu les noms sans regarder les badges
un aller s'il vous plaît on se dit au
revoir tout le monde se dira voit on se
dit au revoir un ayez pas peur
voilà des doigts au revoir on se dit au
revoir voilà tenez je fais la bise là un
fait passé parce que sinon ça va être un
petit peu le jeu fait la bise oui voilà
palper vous un palper vous la relâcher
les tensions la palper la personne qui
est devant n'ayez pas peur
1 mais le temps de faire connaissance
voilà tout le monde sait bien palper
bien reprenant on a quand même un petit
peu de travail est plus que 16 minutes d
intelligence artificielle président
aujourd'hui à nos destinées ainsi qu'à
nos vies quotidiennes internet
internet peut être considéré comme un
super organisme ayant une vie autonome
s'étant propagée au delà des frontières
des religions des cultures et des
régimes politiques l'économie de marché
la finance sont également des super
organisme artificiel qui ont une vie
autonome
nous pouvons y participer nous pouvons
jouer avec nous pouvons influencer sur
fait couler mais personne personne
aujourd'hui ne peut agir sur leur nature
sur leur existence demander d'ailleurs
aux divers gouvernements de votre choix
la seule chose que nous pouvons faire
c'est de participer à leur développement
les nourrir une des conséquences de cela
parce que si nous ne le faisons pas elle
se développe d'elle-même
n'est ce pas un ailleurs autrement sans
nous donc une des conséquences de cela
c'est que nous sommes sollicités
chacun de nous quotidiennement pour être
au top dans notre vie professionnelle
notre vie personnelle
notre vie sociale notre vie familiale
affective citoyenne sexuelle l'éducation
l'alimentation le tri des déchets moins
20% sur les vacances et il faut
également que j'envoie le devis sans
compter mes points retraite rappelé
mamie tu as vu l'heure qu'il est je vois
bien je suis au téléphone
et puis aussi finir le devis avant lundi
je l' ai déjà dit qu'elle temps pour y
envoyer le dossier bouchard acheter des
mouchoirs tout en ayant un avis sur les
conditions de vie au bhoutan qui ne
s'est pas rasé le matin en se disant
mais je ne lis jamais réussir à tout
faire aujourd'hui mais ce pas madame
mais je pense
vous avez raison vous avez raison mais
je pense que il faut que nous cessions
de nous considérer comme des individus
des êtres humains
car si ces entreprises deviennent des
organismes vivants devenons chacun de
nous des entreprises individuelles de
véritables entreprises organique
compétitive et performante avec une
stratégie claire un marketing structurer
une équipe motivée et un produit sans
cesse son renouvellement
nous-mêmes l'inside green management
aide
l'individu à devenir une entreprise si
je décide de devenir un ninja green ma
nature ça veut dire que je décide de
m'appliquer le triple a sur ma vie
audace authenticité accomplissement
amour
avec l'insight green management ensemble
dès aujourd'hui plantons les racines de
deux dans le futur et c'est pour cela
que votre taux qui est certifié iso
14001 et c'est pour cela qu'à guérir
l'inside running management ne se fait
pas comme ça
il ya une méthode précise un protocole
une téquila rapido
et oui et oui une méthode
mesdames et messieurs si nous voulons
changer le monde il est nécessaire d'en
utiliser les règles comme le dit
d'ailleurs si bien l'adage si tu veut
détourner un avion il faut monter dedans
je vous laisse avec ce fameux proverbe
talibans
j'ai pu expérimenter que pour rentrer
dans le mode de pensée inzaghi
management il est toujours nécessaire de
passer par une phase d'échauffement
psycho émotionnel de groupe 1 ne pe
déchets à une coupure ou des guerres où
la ferveur sa propre état c'est un
exercice
un module devrais je dire destiné à
apprendre à s'exprimer en public donc
avec notre outil de communication
premier un autre instrument de travail
notre corps alors je vous propose mon
soir propositions
ensemble ce soir de d'expérimenter un
tout petit peu au dg vous voulez bien
oui oui alors enfin ça c'est vrai que si
spontanément vous vous me répondez oui
jasmin vous me renforcer dans la
confiance dans mon entreprise vous
voulez bien merci
eh bien on peut on peut commencer
simplement avec une articulation va
faire son musique on peut avoir un petit
peu de musique
allez y faites le pour vous hein
c'est un exercice personnel à un
exercice personnel mais d'euros on ne
copie pas sur son voisin un ya pas de
vient pas de marlin on fait ce qu'on
veut on peut juste attention à ne pas
blesser ses voisins voilà allez faites
le compte fait le point voilà voilà
madame si vous avez peur d'être ridicule
regardez moi et voilà ça on lâche un
pensez-y
lundi matin comme ça on arrive à un
petit réunion de travail coûte tout de
suite ça relâche les tensions un mot si
j'adore faire ça
bah alors ceux qui ne savent pas quoi
faire on peut se palper la pulpe allez
on se palpent la pulpe s'il vous plaît
on se bat peut l'appeler peu là-bas
voilà monsieur si vous vous palpez la
pulpe les mains dans les poches vous
allez vous faire très mal
voilà très bien à lyon se palpent la
pulpe et on se parle de la balme
je vous vois un et on se parle l'autre
pall mall avec la pulpe sus décrites et
les pulls et les palmes et si ça va trop
vite monsieur on peut se palper le pouls
et les pulls et les pages et les bulls
et les cultes et les palmes et les
palmes et les palmes et les pub télé pub
télé pub télé parle mais les pulls que
les parcs et les palmes et le goût et
les passes et les puce mais les plus
sûrs du chillou plein et les pubs et les
pubs et les palmes et les cuisses et le
pouls et le fouet les fous et les poêler
les genoux et vous et les femmes et tous
les poulets poil et le goût et les
palmes et les palmes et les palmes et
les palmes et les palmes et les palmiers
les palme revient très bien on peut
arrêter très bon groupe
vous savez c'est avec un esprit tel que
celui là que vous allez m'aider à vous
aider à devenir de vrais insa green
manager ça en tout cas c'est mon taf et
son mari ciab ses matches au bail alors
connaître son outil de travail c'est
nécessaire mais ce n'est pas suffisant
un lit il faut savoir comment l'utiliser
verront l'utiliser dans quel secteur il
est le plus approprié et souvent on a
besoin de faire un grand audit interne
je vous propose mon soir propositions
pour ce grand audit ensemble ce soir de
se connecter à son mammifères intimes
vous voulez bien
a été bon très bien alors on laisse
travailler un petit peu son bureau
recherche et développement un voilà et
on applique tout de suite hein ce qu'on
a appris en e p dg vous et on laisse
venir le ou les mammifères intime qui
viennent surtout par ippon
pas de jugement entre nous ce qui est
important de se rappeler c'est ce que
nous allons faire
on se bat ensemble 1
c'est vrai on nous dit tellement ça va
peut-être vous n'imaginez pas tout ce
qu'on peut faire pour vous nous
travaillons en ut jour pour vous
nous non plus belles destinations c'est
vous notre plus beau voyage chez vous
d'ailleurs si chez lui c'est pour vous
voilà allez s'il vous plaît allez c'est
fait le fait que pour vous un voilà
allez allez chacun chacun pour soi voilà
ah ah ah ah ah ah bon oeil la techno pop
ohlala voilà voilà voilà un an il est
important de faire venir son mammifères
intime mais il faut quand même garder le
contrôle des opérations sinon ça devient
n'importe quoi
là
elle avait laissé continuer que je
sombre ans
et
et là
m
allez ah non non non allez-y ont fait
les animaux de la ferme
allez-y
attendez attendez attendez non je vois
qu'il y en a qui travaillent pour
d'autres mesdames et messieurs il faut
partir du principe que si tout le monde
le fait personne n'est ridicule
1 vous avez vu les dents tout à l'heure
allez on fait les animaux de la ferme
voilà voilà
un bijou est un bijou et y est mêlé au
petit jeu où c'est très bien c'est c'est
très bien c'est très bien mais je
réponds d'ores et déjà certaines des
questions que je reçois oui mon
mammifères à tim peut-être un dindon
oui il peut être une poule commande fait
des fun tu si on n'arrive pas à penser
différemment
comment voulez vous que nous des
broussailles ont de nouvelles pistes que
nous développions de nouvelles cultures
enfin que nous allions vers des secteurs
plus éloignés nous scotche le végétal le
végétal
je vous propose
bonsoir propositions
non pas de faire pousser ou fleurir
votre légumes intime mais plutôt quelque
chose de depuis collectif de ce que
comme un marché commun quelque chose de
comme une grande forêt solidaire unisexe
substrat ternel à champs de blé un
voulez bien
l'un d'eux qui suivent ainsi vous feront
vous aviez une méthode quand même allez
allez puisqu'on va tous faire la même
chose mais quand même vous montrer un
petit peu de théorie alors l'épi de blé
à l'épi de blé vous avez lépi vous avez
la tige en lui-même vous voyez vous avez
lépi de l'épi de part et d'autre part'
des bars bull 1 et l'épi de blé
naturellement heureux
allez tout le monde en épis de blé tout
le monde en épis de blé tout le monde
aurait pu doubler avant voilà très bien
très bien et on fait l'épi de blé dans
le vent voilà elle regarde la
retransmission web cam
c'est ça tu fais quoi la souche
allez allez on fait l'épisode les allées
au nom du loup petits champs de blé
ondulé dans le vent voilà un peu on peut
caresser son son petit frère sa petite
soeur épis de blé l'a11 on sent l'envié
d'un des ses vêtements qui se fait de
plus en plus fort un en épis de blé
l'eau on n'a pas mentionné encore qu'est
ce que tu fais l'épeautre m'en aller
voilà bah oui monsieur sous le soleil en
chanson petit et puis qui dit à tous
ferme 1 attendez tout le monde être si
tout le monde tout le monde un champ de
blé là tout le monde en chine du ps
c'est très très important s'il vous
plaît c'est son corps de dix secondes
c'est alesi alesi n'ayez pas peur vous
allez voir si voilà tout le monde en
champs de blé et c'est très important
mesdames et messieurs surtout avec des
gens que vous ne connaissez pas regardez
vous les uns les autres
regardez vous regardez vous regardez
regardez vous voyez observé constaté un
campus dans une direction fertile mais
mesdames et messieurs
pour répondre à ces intelligences
artificielles qui tentent de nuuk les
dévier artificielle vous le constater
maintenant vous le sentez
indubitablement vous le voyez que
l'insight green management ce qu'il fait
à l'intérieur se voit l'extérieur je
vous remercie
merci
merci infiniment